je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
et non mais tu viens de m'offrir s'est
passée la première bouteille luc dossier
lui envieraient la cannelle loïc david
c'est toi qui l'as cannes c'est la
première bouteille il me l'année pour
moi
l'original zain au regard d'un braqueur
merci alors norbert et gens vous allez
être opposé pour un happening cuisine
isabelle morini bosc et gilles verdez
vous avez donc deux bras donc un bras
chacun et vous allez devoir faire une
omelette d'accord isabelle morini bosc
et gilles verdez c'est l'équipe qui fera
le plus vite le net vous avez une minute
pour faire une omelette les ingrédients
gregor d'abord alors prenez d'abord les
ingrédients ont été saisis mon or baer
mon chéri tu est écouté mon frérot et tu
viens pas nous voir sur le plateau
comment ça se fait pas le temps de venir
et pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe après
que les décomptes mon nom alors que tu
devais venir aujourd'hui finalement tu
viens pas il ya eu des petits soucis
mais toi tu veux venir absolument en
fait c'est ça n'a pas beaucoup bougé pas
c'est quoi le truc est bouché j'ai pas
compris assez 38 quoi ah d'accord merci
attention c'est show attention c'est
show commence à ce phénomène bieber la
longue lettre vous voulez me faire
arrêter là et moi j'ai trois
chorégraphies maintenant encore un deux
trois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la meilleure c'est comme ça les fera ce
qu on va appeler le goûteur de
l'émission gérard louvin qui était
ancien que les spécialités non alors mis
pour gérard est magnifique c'est la
magnifique parfaitement à sa folie keane
est meilleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]